most black holes start life with the
death of a giant star
when the star collapses it all gets
blown out in the most violent fireworks
in the universe a supernova the
explosion of a star which shines briefly
with the brightness of 10 billion stars
then gravity seizes control of the
star's core a star it's already crushing
itself down under gravity but what stops
it is the pressure of the light coming
out of it so if a star can no longer
produce that light it's gonna crush
itself down in order to get smaller and
smaller and smaller until finally no
force can hold it up and it just crushes
it on itself gravity pulls every speck
of matter inwards crushing lumps of
solid iron the size of Mount Everest
down to the size of grains of sand
we think about solid matter as being
something that's so solid so strong that
it can't compress anymore think of iron
but really iron is mostly space the
space between the protons and neutrons
at the core of that iron atom is huge so
at some point for some stars the
compression is so large that you can end
up smashing these core neutrons and
protons together what happens next is a
mystery gravity squeezes these subatomic
particles together in ways that science
simply can't explain the inside of a
collapsing star is unimaginable there
are temperatures and pressures that we
don't really even have very good numbers
for we know for a fact that we will need
new physics things that we have not yet
discovered to explain what goes on
inside a black hole the massive star
crushes down until it's a fraction of
its former size
but the stars original gravity remains
creating a gravitational field so strong
nothing can escape it the result is a
black hole